I'm Stacey seltzer I'm the senior vice
president for content acquisition and
strategy at juiced and a graduate of the
columbia business school so i'm excited
to be here this afternoon thank you guys
for having me joost is a new company
from a couple of guys who have kind of
rebel eyes revolutionized the world in a
couple different arenas janus friis and
Nicholas is Enstrom and they were they
first created a company called Kazaa and
of course learned a few lessons out of
that one and then of course they went
and created a company called skype but
what these guys were basically really
good at doing is they they're really
good at creating this technology that we
traditionally have called peer-to-peer
but what that's really about doing is
moving bits and bytes around the
internet in an extremely efficient
manner and so in the first iteration of
that they used it to allow people to
share files and that was Kazan and the
second iteration of this this
peer-to-peer technology it's the
background that powers skype Jenelle has
a hundred and eighty-one million
registered users and you know at any
given time 89 million phone calls going
on a particular time so with juste what
they've done is they've taken that same
technology in its third generation and
optimized it to deliver video over the
public internet and as you see is it
I've got the client running here and
I'll just let it run for a little bit
while you guys can play or while I talk
you get full screen sight sound in
motion joost is a downloadable software
client like skype or kazan but it's a
closed network so we only work with
professional content owners
and as as Johnson nickels worth thinking
about the company and and they were
considering there were a lot of
companies out there that when they
thought about the television experience
on video threats they seem to be
internet companies first started out as
an Internet company and then brought the
video experience to it we wanted to turn
that idea on its head and start with the
television experience the kind of full
screen sight sound and motion experience
and then bring all the cool stuff about
the internet to it and so as you see it
goes full screen you know video
initially but after that what we do is
we take all and it's really neat to see
some of the presentations that have been
going on this afternoon because you
really begin to think about all the
interactivity and all the great things
that the Internet can bring to a video
experience and harness them in in this
kind of way so when a user interacts
with the system they get the overlays
this is just the kind of menu but
basically at the top in here we get a
commercial but at the top is kind of the
content donors area on on the right is
the community area at the bottom of the
control bar and it left the channel
programming
I'm going to I've clicked here on this
top area but actually i'm going to
switch channels for a second
so and again this is just running live
it's a streaming experience over the
Internet I was connected to the Wi-Fi
here earlier and checking out to see if
it would run at the top here is the
content owners area you know in this
case it could be a public broadcaster it
could be a channel yeah the University
Channel or an educators Channel and this
is where we can begin to take advantage
of all the interactivity that we've all
been talking about is beginning to be
developed in a really exciting way I
mean seeing some of those demonstrations
about what you know mapping the galaxies
and things like that and beginning to
think about it directly linking that to
a big screen video experience like this
is really exciting and we're certainly
working on that we're also very much
about the community and I'm kind of
breezing through this because I'm
conscious of time but we've developed a
platform by which people can create
widgets to begin to have new
interactions with content and new ideas
about how new experiences in sharing
content and sharing community
experiences and so again the application
of this to an educational environment is
kind of you know it's natural and ended
very exciting the ideas of class mates
here Sharon notes or having a channel
chat while they're going you know
talking about a particular lecture the
ability to build all that metadata and
tag programs and share experiences over
the content and allow students and the
community to do this itself is very
exciting to us we've built out a bunch
of kind of things that a lot of this
we're still in beta so it's proof of
concept but you know we have things like
ratings and the ability to begin to put
in describe what the programs are doing
at the bottom is our control bar it's
pretty straightforward but again it uses
all that rich metadata that that we can
do on the on the
you can harness in the internet to
organize and provide more information
about the content that's available until
you can see this and that it also allows
you to navigate through the system you
know we're a channel different driven
system it's like television and we
wanted to provide the kind of Leanback
experience of just sitting back and
being entertained and so you can do that
you can choose MTV and go in there and
just watch whatever his program comes up
and sit there until and watch Laguna
Beach tow your hearts you know content
or you can go in and specifically go and
choose the particular items that you
wanted to see so it gives you that TiVo
or kind of full VOD experience in that
same way it's also scalable and sizable
application this might mess up based on
the scaling but you can always take it
down not that anyone would probably do
this in class or at work but they could
proceed to go and use other aspects of
you know on their computer lastly in
terms of the system we have a channel
guide which is just another way we're
very conscious about content discovery
there's so much kind of clutter out
there and so we're very focused on
allowing people a combination of
editorial and algorithmic and neutral
ways of navigating content of sharing
content and beginning to experience new
things so I wanted to quickly just show
you guys the system its most fun when
you can just watch it like that I'll go
back to the National Geographic thing
just because it shows that the
incredible quality which can be
delivered just using this experience you
know we're very early company joost is
still in beta we're in what we call our
friends and family beta and I would be
happy by the way anyone who wants to
leave a business card or an email i'm
happy off
everybody on the beta for you guys to
check it out and right now we're mostly
working with commercial companies we
have some NGOs and that we've also been
working with like witness and some other
programs but most of we've been working
with commercial clients I myself am very
excited about the possibilities of
bringing this into the educational realm
and I think you know again just seeing
some of the things that have been
demonstrated here show the huge
potential for this medium so we're you
know we're very open to those kind of
discussions and and will be proceeding
that way so we'll be out of beta over
the next few months so with that I think
I'll just quickly let you guys proceed